fue durante una inmersión recreativa con
un club polaco francés local que la
investigadora letizia head se encontró
con una rareza impresionante
es simplemente maravilloso lo que es muy
interesante es que el arrecife parece no
tener fin
efe hasta donde alcanza la vista a lo
largo de tres kilómetros los buzos se
encontraron algo parecido a un jardín o
vastos grupos de corales en forma de
rosa en perfectas condiciones con el
patrocinio de la unesco se organizó una
expedición para estudiar el área virgen
a diferencia de la mayoría de los
arrecifes conocidos que se encuentran en
aguas poco profundas y son muy
vulnerables al cambio climático ya la
sobrepesca este arrecife se encuentra en
lo que los científicos llaman la zona
crepuscular un área ubicada entre 30 y
70 metros de profundidad
hay algunas personas que piensan bueno
encontramos este recife en aguas
profundas así que no tenemos que
preocuparnos por los arrecifes de coral
en otros lugares pero no estará sujeto a
alguna de las mismas amenazas y también
es diferente en menor diversidad que los
arrecifes poco profundos
los arrecifes de coral son hábitats
vitales esenciales para la vida marina
se cree que este tiene alrededor de 25
años su profundidad significa que es
difícil y costoso de estudiar como la
gran mayoría de los fondos oceánicos de
la tierra
solo tenemos alrededor del 20 por ciento
del fondo del océano que ha sido
cartografiado en alta resolución es
asombroso cuando piensas que tienes una
mejor imagen de la luna de marte como lo
es cuando te das cuenta de que esta
información es realmente la base para la
gestión de los océanos para la
conservación los buzos creen que el
reciente volcán en la cercana tonga no
afectó al arrecife pero su
descubrimiento es un recordatorio de las
impresionantes maravillas que yacen bajo
la superficie